hi I'm Glenn Schofield artist and video
game director and I'm here to answer
your questions from Twitter this is
video game support
[Music]
Dr Bruce Wayne why do horror games scare
me when horror movies don't laugh out
loud because it's immersive you are
right there that is you that is great to
hear because that's what we try to do we
try and the more we immerse you and make
you feel like you're the character the
more you're gonna get scared trust me
rusky bruh
why don't startup Studios just make
their own game engine like bro stop
being lazy wow okay well my teams have
made plenty of engines and they are hard
they take years and years especially for
the nowadays you need to take an old
engine and and rework it but making an
engine from scratch
in today's market is going to take you
years and millions of dollars and uh
you'll still get it wrong by the time I
got to uh EA you know they had a lot of
different engines around we were
starting to build one where for Lord of
the Rings and I don't know they were
about a year into it I said that what
are we doing we're we're two years away
so we looked around
and we got creative Lord of the Rings is
about large areas and then sort of a a
castle on the end or or something a
fortress what's like that Tiger Woods
long areas and at the end is where you
go get food where you're done and so we
took the Tiger Woods engine and turned
that into the uh Lord of the Rings
engine you just have to be smart about
what you do and what you use for an
engine
paragama doinks
I'm sure I got that wrong what steps do
I need to take to be a video game
director because I feel like I can be
the video game Spielberg good for you
that's confidence to be a video game
director you're you're gonna have to
move up the ranks uh you got to learn
the inside and and outside of video
games so you just can't come in and do
it no way you got to have a lot of
knowledge you can come up in in many
different ways I came up through the art
field you know I started as an artist in
video games I've seen people come up as
uh from producers you're gonna need
experience uh you're gonna need to know
everything about the video game I don't
need to know the technology but I need
to understand it and it's changing in
every game so you just can't jump in
uh I'm sorry uh does semporium do horror
game creators get scared of their own
creation sometimes
no what happens really is that after a
while you've played the game so many
times you don't know if it's scary or
not if in the beginning the first time
that you know I say hey let's let's do
this here and if the first time I see it
I jump or I get scared then I know it's
uh it's good hold on I've got something
so this
it's two head from the Callisto protocol
I'm sure that the first time you see him
you will be very scared we went through
a lot of iterations to get to this he's
morphed into two heads and you can
actually blow off either side and one
head will fall off and they'll still be
coming at you with half his body so he's
pretty scary and uh he's really hard to
kill
Yoshi why are video games sixty dollars
why are they all sixty dollars who
agreed on that I don't know who agreed
on all that I surely didn't I think that
it's the console guys who uh come up
with the cost but there may be uh some
of the Publishers have something to do
with it but I gotta be honest with you
they've been like 50 60 dollars for what
a decade something like that and which
Time games have doubled or quadrupled in
cost
and the price hasn't gone up and you can
see the difference between a PlayStation
2 game and a PlayStation 5 game and
you're almost paying the same price man
I don't want to put the cost on on the
on the fan and I don't
um but they're expensive to make they
really are add Spirit Destiny how do you
write a video game script well it's
pretty complex I don't consider myself a
writer I consider myself a Storyteller
so I'll write 20 Pages or something on
what this game was and once I have a
story and I've talked to everybody sort
of into it and through it and whatever
we bring on our writers the next two
three years the writers are working with
me and they're writing the script and
they're adding the characters and and
things like that so it is a long process
because a video game is a is is pretty
long 10 12 13 hours something like that
so the scripts are big they change a lot
because this is about gameplay and
something might not be fun we leave a
lot of room for change at Sea could tell
who makes up these game ratings comic
Mischief come on really
I don't have a problem with the games
ladies it seems like most games that
deserve an M get an M I've never had a
problem with a games rating I think
maybe in the early days we had one a
problem with one in Europe and we worked
on that one of the European countries
but at the end of the day uh we talked
them into what it what it should be I
don't have a problem with it now but the
critic scores oh boy I could talk to you
all day about that Aika 95. I never knew
that motion capture process also
included with voice acting recording or
did they record that separately and did
a lip mimic on motion capture there's
another process called performance
capture or what we call pcap and that's
actually where we capture the voice
acting on motion capture uh it's really
just about the movements the Fidelity
isn't the same as performance capture
which are big stages that we actually
have to go down to Hollywood to do
there's only only a couple down there so
we go down and Sony one and here's an
example of us getting the motion of a
kill scene
Primo Dodges he strikes to the legs
which swipes him out he comes up
crack splits the head open right okay we
don't really do the the lips or the
voice here on motion capture but we'll
get 75 of the moves for the game at
least uh in the motion capture Studio
sorry I'm not good at making scary
things how do horror games come up with
the most unnerving stuff play a lot of
scary games watch a lot of uh movies if
you're passionate about anything right
you're gonna get into it you're gonna be
studying it you're going to be absorbed
in it for years I've been like a sci-fi
horror fan since I was really young I'm
constantly thinking about it constantly
have ideas in my head so you know I know
I have some but for us you know I put it
out to the team we got 200 people we're
gonna they're gonna come up with ideas
I'm always asking them for ideas because
it's not about my ideas always getting
in the game it's about the best ideas
getting in the game I don't care where
it comes from so we're constantly asking
the team and having brainstorming
meetings and doing things like that
because the second part to it and how do
the creators of them not like scare the
[ __ ] out of themselves when looking at
their own assets you know sometimes I
gotta tell you like with the gore system
that we have in in our new game the
first time I saw some of that stuff I
was uh shocked not necessarily like
scared but I was really psyched because
I'm like that's brand new haven't seen
that that's gonna gross people out
especially on the latest platforms I
mean consoles
man this stuff looks amazing at two fool
why are video games important video
games are uh I think incredibly
important they are an art form It's
Entertainment it's a social network
they're just you know part of Pop
Culture now they are part of our world
video games are bigger than movies and
music combined doubled they're that huge
I also think that they're the next
medium we're already doing it to tell a
great story I mean look at video games
and the difference between where they
were 10 years ago and where they are
today a huge jump we're always working
on next technology what's the next thing
uh you know movies which I love 10 years
ago to today it's not a big leap right
but video games are constantly
constantly changing that's one of the
hardest thing about making them but it's
also one of the funnest things
at x24 Sonic it's a long one how the
[ __ ] do you design levels like in the
survival horror game building how do you
decide which rooms are locked or empty
and and what order the player will go
through them how do you come up with the
layout and progression because I don't
know where to start that could take me
all day to answer but uh we start out
with a paper idea a paper map we we have
software now that we can lay it out
pretty quickly and we move things around
and stuff like that and this is done by
the designers so the designers are
laying out the gameplay when people look
at it and go hey that looks pretty good
we don't know yet but well we think it
looks good we'll then go into
our engine and we lay it out in blocks
we call it block world very simple mesh
we put a character in and we run through
it
uh if we like that we then have the
artists look at it because the designer
is just something that fun so sometimes
they'll have a hallway going to a
bathroom and the bathroom have a second
door that goes into a bedroom so we have
to get it right the artist will go in
and make sure architecturally the
building is correct and and tell them we
have to rework it a bit as far as which
ones are locked and uh and which ones
are empty and everything that comes with
the gameplay that's usually probably 50
percent is uh uh has got on your uh
paper map over the course of making a
level and making a level can take two
years because you're working on it
working on iterating putting the enemies
in so it takes a long time these things
change at Angelo's end why are the
simplest games always the best I hear
what you're saying but I don't
necessarily agree some of the simplest
games are great right it's easy to get
in easy to understand and you don't have
a lot of startup time right to get into
it you know rocket league and even Call
of Duty to an extent is easy to get into
these days I mean it's hard to play
against a lot of people but
um I like games that take not a long
long time to get into it but they build
up the mechanics a bit it takes a little
while and you're learning the story and
all so I'm not always about the simplest
game
but I understand what you're saying
at Jeff Whitmore one what is the
scariest video game ever very good
question and I'm sure a lot of people
have different answers but mine has got
to be one of the Silent Hills probably
Silent Hill too I mean when that horn
went off and I knew Pyramid Head was
coming at me I just ran and that was
terrifying or you're in the fog your
little geiger counter goes off and you
knew something was around you just
really frightening so great game scared
the heck out of me
um I wish they would make more portable
G some great names here what makes a
good hard game Well I obviously one that
you keep wanting to go through it right
because you know you're gonna just get
scared but if you want to play the whole
thing that's a good horror game but what
makes it good well I think story is
important I think story will pull you
through right obviously tension and
Sound and Music will get you through not
being frustrated that is a fine line
when we're when we're making a game you
know we can make something then that
kills you 10 times but you'll you'll
just throw your controller and blame us
but if you die like three times you're
kind of blaming yourself and you want to
get through it again so we are really
careful about how hard you make it um we
get analytics and and watch people play
and and all sorts of things so we don't
want you too frustrated somebody said to
me once they're like what I loved about
dead space was that every level I knew
you were gonna show me something new and
exciting and different whether it scared
me or not and I couldn't put it down at
Adele Pinot music how important is sound
design for a video game wow right up my
alley uh especially for a horror game
sound design and music and everything
else is 50 of the game right it's 50 of
the horror I consider uh music and audio
in a horror game a feature it's a
mechanic it's that important and you
know for all my other video games I've
been sitting in the booths with the
audio directors for 20 years it's that
important to me but in a horror game
it's a mechanic let's say you're doing a
uh a machine well for a scary game the
machine should sound scary and so we
make sure that everything we kind of put
in even though it's relatable it's gonna
have a weird or an off-putting sound and
then we get the music in and when I say
music it's not music as you know I mean
it's scary it's got weird instruments
sometimes it gets a little abstract and
the whole idea here is to add that
tension and that's the key to a horror
game because then you can make your
scares much better and much bigger
because they're already sort of dense
and then at that point when we do a
scare what we call a stinger here's an
example of a stinger from the Callisto
protocol
thank you
It's gotta be on point It's gotta be
right there right on the money or it's
not going to be good so we spent a lot
of time uh getting the timing right at
the one for DJ ytf is Elden ring so hard
bro well I guess that's subjective but
uh yeah from what I hear I haven't
played it all right pretty busy right
now with this video game from what I
hear yes it's very hard
but uh that's sort of what's going on in
the video game industry right now and
I've seen it go up and down over the
years sometimes they get a little bit
easier and then they get a little bit
harder we're going through that period
right now and matter of fact uh we're
gonna make ours pretty tough too I just
think it's it's sort of that point in
video games and uh just keep playing
you'll get through it at tdsn 19. how
well does a finger Mo cap work
well I have one right here it's awesome
we used to have to animate the fingers
and it was a lot of work you know you've
mooc out the whole thing then you got to
go in because the hands got to look
right they got to grip the guns they got
to grip this they got a punch they've
saved us a lot of time a lot of energy
and a lot of a lot of headaches well
worth their money and uh they work great
at Nick Gage one I always wonder how
long does motion capture usually take to
finish by having a motion capture stage
here at uh Striking Distance Studios
we're able to capture motion every day
if we need to get a run we can do a run
in the morning by the afternoon the run
is in the game might need a little tweak
here and there or or maybe uh you know
something to get it from one animation
to the other we do it in real time and
then we just take that motion and we uh
put it in game so it's it's uh it's
really quick and that's what makes uh
quality for us being here in the studio
gives us the ability to have quality
because we can do something over and
over and over again and the key to video
games is iteration
it's hard what is your favorite monster
design in a video game is there any
obscure ones you think deserve more
praise wow I have seen some great ones
uh I mentioned Pyramid Head uh before
Pyramid Head is is just weird right and
so I gotta hand it to them for that that
one I like nemesis from Resident Evil I
mean Resident Evil over the years just
has some really good ones but I I think
I'm gonna stick with those two for now
ah big ass Luigi how the hell do game
physics work do you have to give the
program the formula for gravity or what
I'm not an engineer I'm an artist but
yes we've been working with physics for
you know 20 30 years now
um so game physics some of that is when
the character Falls they hit the ground
right that's gotta look good and that's
game physics in in itself that is a huge
thing that we have in games and it's
very expensive that's why sometimes when
a character is dead on the ground you go
to kick them they don't move in some
games because if they move you're
talking about
just using a performance and things like
that so that's why you see that the
formula for gravity or no that's that we
don't have to do that now zero g which
we had in uh in one of my games that
space we had to take it because you're
floating around and that took a lot of
work it was like uh when we have to do
swimming and put them in them in water
it had to feel something like that and
I'll tell you when uh one of the secrets
of uh Dead Space was you know when
you're in zero g you're kind of moving
differently well we put it in what was
we thought was real zero g timing it
started feeling sluggish so we did was
we gave it the same amount of speed as
the regular walk but we made the
animation look slower
and so we never got that sluggishness
and uh no one ever knew that it was the
same size no uh same speed no one ever
got back to us at Hannah marief can
someone explain to me why I get actual
anxiety when I'm playing a video game as
if I might be shot in real life well
let's hope that doesn't happen Hannah
the anxiety uh is of course you don't
want to die you don't want to you don't
have to start over everybody whatever
you've uh accumulated whether it's going
through the level or you know upgrades
and stuff you don't want to lose that
you've earned that so I think that's
part of it in a hard game the anxiety is
what we want you to have all throughout
it anxiety and tension because then we
can scare you more so that is something
that we try and manufacture if a game
isn't manufacturing it like on purpose
like we are it just comes from and I
want to start over not wanting to go to
a checkpoint not wanting to die I think
well that's all the questions for today
uh I I appreciate you sending them in
and uh
I hope you learned something
[Music]